maybe you've heard that Hebrew and
Arabic are written entirely in
consonants wrong here's why you're back
in old Phoenicia where it turns out the
Greeks aren't the only ones looking to
buy a vowel your contact in town is
still your merchant frenemy who reminds
you of how she traded your consonant
alphabet across the ancient world that
objets bread to every language with even
a passing resemblance to Phoenicians
every town from here to carthage has
some version of her objet spot the
Egyptians those stuck in their way
traditionalists initially these Semitic
speakers loved it they were proud of it
but the days are turning to years and
that love grows cold they grumble that
they're stuck with these consonants just
consonants clamoring for vowels they get
desperate and grab a few characters to
stand in for a long sound take a look
this symbol is originally the stop
between ha this one's a y by yo sound
and this is a whoa but they're about to
become not these things thanks to major
moments in the history of writing this
moment hits you twice because it brings
up both an innovation specific to
semitic scripts and a more general
principle that kind of bends the rules
of the alphabet game first it's worth
reiterating that objects are viable ways
to write and read a language they work
but with one obvious shortcoming those
missing vowels can create ambiguous
situations but what if instead of
writing every vowel we just had a few
helpful hint ORS that suggested the
presence of certain kinds of vowels take
this letter what actually they called it
Wow Wow
now imagine that we keep using it in
words that have the sound what but we
also extend its use placing it between
consonants for the similar enough vowel
sound whew in the old objet have to
write soon and son with the same
characters s plus in everything else is
vowels and we don't have those but
suddenly our extended walk comes in
handy son doesn't have that sound so
it's still s plus in but soon does so we
add in the W do the same thing with you
which can double as a long eye and this
quirky cat
your throat pause between uh-oh LF which
can double as along ah and you end up
with three handy vowels adjusters the
mattress lectio knees these helpful
mothers of reading that show up in
aramaic hebrew arabic and Syriac but
these mothers don't leave their
consonant 'no spend they still double as
consonants the object raided the
ambiguity of a vowel this existence for
new kind of ambiguity depending on
context each of these mattress may be a
consonant or it might be a vowel one
character multiple sounds this is a huge
trend in alphabet why invent new
characters when you can reuse an old one
repurposing consonants for vowels here
and there won't satisfy everyone these
bickering scribes aren't content with
mattress like Theo knees they're not
just trying to tell son apart from soon
the bickering scribes are bickering over
how to read one of their most treasured
sayings one says that it's such a fine
point you wouldn't understand unless you
were incredibly well versed in his
language but he makes an analogy for you
right the word news in a consonant only
alphabet it's in WS high
now imagine that someone comes along
with their fancy consonant vowel hybrids
and spells the word noose in WS hmm wait
a second he shows you a cheat sheet he's
been keeping it's so easy he says
pointing out the little dots and dashes
above and below letters to keep his
vowel straight put them here for an oo
there for an A you can even add them
below one of the long vowel things if
you need to distinguish say an e
nobody's confused that's it he won't
tolerate the vagueness any longer
effective immediately in all important
text we're clear reading matters
everyone's to use this method and so for
generations scribes with mark vowels
above and below the consonants writing
vowels in what was once a consonant only
alphabet but as much as the pious and
students swear by their dotty vowels
modern Arabic and Hebrew speakers stick
with the simple consonants plus the
extended consonant vowel mothers the
optional helper dots get thrown in like
a life preserver for struggling learners
or careful text but grown-ups don't need
them anymore
let's take you
you